Is there some sort of progression of symptoms when someone has lymphoma and then starts your
life and supplement program? Do people go through different stages before they're cancer-free?
How soon will there be changes? It's been two months and I've not really noticed any decrease
in the intra-abdominal mass. Well three days ago, I started having pain in that area. Is that a sign
that the immune system is attacking that area? Well, I do have a video and a blog post on good-paid
bad-paid that will maybe help you discern that. There's no perfect way to discern whether my
pain is a good-paid or a bad-paid. They say, well, how could there be any good-paid? Well,
if your immune system is attacking a site, you're going to have an increase in inflammation at that
site. That's what an uptick of the immune system is. So you get a B bite, the B sting, and you
have all this inflammation because of the B sting, because your immune system is setting this entire
immune attack, trying to deal with this inflammatory thing that is pulsating toxins into your system.
So the same thing, when you're up, trying to uptick your immune system to fight a cancer, you could
have an increase in inflammation at that site, and have pain because of that. So I don't know
if that's a good-paid or a bad-paid. So if you're saying that you can feel like you
are able to adequately examine a mass, whether it's a breast mass or a mass that's from lymphoma,
and adequately measure the size, and you can say, after two months, it's not changing size.
Does that mean it's a bad thing? Maybe, maybe not. So remember, when we're trying to kill cancer,
we're trying to extend someone's life. We're not... I don't... In our mind, we're always thinking,
I want this to go away. You have a mass in your breast or you have a mass, you know, in your
abdominal cavity, and it's lymphoma, or it's a breast cancer. I want this to go away. Of course,
we all want it to go away, but really, when you think about it, what is cancer? Cancer is rapidly
replicating cells. If we could stop it rapidly replicating, and our body would just wall it off,
wouldn't that be just as good? Well, maybe mentally, it would be better for you,
for me to have it to disappear, and then we don't see it anymore. But realistically,
when you have a fairly large mass, it's going to be more difficult for the body to remove that
mass, to break it down, to get it out of your body, to get rid of the cells, and for you to detox it,
is that it would be for your body to wall it off and have it not grow. Really, we want, you know,
a mass to stop growing. Of course, I agree. We want it to go away, but we want it to stop growing,
and as far as how long does it take for that to take place? Well, to be honest, we may have to tweak
your program and change things to get it moving in that right direction. And then also, honestly,
it may take months for it, just with the brakes on it, for it to start shrinking. And then,
thirdly, it may just stop growing and be walled off and never change size. And you live another 40 years
with this mass of dead cells in your abdominal cavity. That's a possibility, too.
So, how do we know what is happening with that? The only perfect way to know if a mass that
has not changed size, let's say it's not getting bigger, it's not getting smaller, it's still the same
size. And let's say now, instead of being two months out, or two years out, how would we know if this
is still active cancer or not? The only way to know at that point would be to go in and remove it
and then do a pathology report on it. So, you cut it in slices and you look at it at a microscope,
if they're all dead cells. Of course, you're always going to do that because there's danger of that, too.
I actually had this story multiple times and I had a lung cancer patient who had multiple masses
in her chest. And she refused to let the surgeon remove him. He was trying to get her to remove him
I can't remember how long of a time it was. Finally, she was persuaded, this is a surgeon at Mayo,
that talked her into doing it. He said it was going to be a relatively quick surgery. The surgery took
like five times longer than he thought because the tumors that he thought was active cancer was
just walled off dead cells that broke apart. Like the word he used, the surgeon used was he broke
it broke apart like a puff ball and it made a mess in that person's lungs and it took forever to
clean it out. So, maybe you should have let sleeping giants lie. You know, I'm not saying that's
the case we need to measure. We need to look at all sorts of different things. Like I said, with that
previous question, look at blood work and look at scans and look at subjective findings as well.
So, feeling great and feeling fantastic. If I still have this mass, it's not getting any bigger,
but it's concerning because it's not getting any smaller. While you weigh it out with as many
possible things that you could do to weigh out whether I'm getting better or not.